>> Ankur: Alright.
Welcome everyone.
Thank you for joining us for another Android
Developer Lab Plus. [clears throat] We didn't
run the episode last week.
But we are here today.
And today's topic is actually in app billing.
But before I go ahead with introducing the
topic, let's see who else has joined us live.
So firstly, Anirudh.
>>Anirudh: Hi guys.
I'm Anirudh Dewani.
Based out of Hyderabad.
>>Tony: Hi.
I'm Tony Chan.
I'm based out of Hong Kong.
>>Ankur: And I'm Ankur Kotwal and I'm coming
to you live from Sydney.
So, let's get started with this.
The first section we have is news.
And Tony's going to introduce it.
>>Tony: Sure.
So the first news we have this week is, can
we jump to the next line please?
>>Ankur: Sure.
>>Tony: So we have a new BTU number four for
our Android developer tools.
There's no new feature.
But there are a lot of bugs fixes in this
release.
The second news I want to talk about is, we
now published the app template documentations.
So I think we need to jump the next bullet.
To show the short length.
So basically, we introduce earlier something
called application templates.
So it's a tool for developer to easily get
started by building Android applications.
And we want to share this actually with developers.
So that you can build your own templates.
And so we have some template guidelines to
format.
I mean in order to build your own.
And it's covered in one of a Google+ post
by our colleague Roman Nurik.
And the [unintelligible] is here.
So, the third news I want to mention is, we're
going to have an event in Hong Kong.
It's a GD, Google Developer Group event in
Hong Kong coming up on the 24th.
It's in the evening, in the [Kowloon Si] of
Hong Kong in the InnoCentre.
So the details you can find in this short
link.
And we have and that night I will be there.
And also Ankur and [ unintelligible] Felix
Three of us will be speaking on Android in
different topics.
So hopefully if you are in Hong Kong or you're
based in Hong Kong we look forward to seeing
you on 24th.
>>Ankur: We're looking forward to meeting
those developers in Hong Kong.
Last week, or earlier this week we got to
meet some developers in Korea and that was
a really great experience.
So we're looking forward to seeing more in
more developer's event in Hong Kong.
[inaudible]
So today's topic, as I mentioned, is in-app
billing.
So in-app billing is something we introduced
last year.
And it's really taken the market by storm.
Back then it was called Android Market.
But it's, it's proven to be a very successful
business model for a lot of apps.
So, it's really enabled the freemium model,
where the app itself is free and your users
can get a taste for the type of experience
or utility that your app provides.
And then they can choose to pay for more of
whatever it is that you're selling in your
app.
So don't just think about it from a games
point of view.
It's also a great migration path to convert
free users to paid users.
So the old model of offering a light version
and a pro version.
It's still valid but really in-app billing
makes it even, even better.
Because you don't need to have two different
app listings.
You can have a single one.
Users can pay from the one upgrade and continue
their experience from within your app itself.
Often when you upgrade from the light to pro,
the user has to go and download the pro version.
They end up with two different versions of
your app on their device.
And you have to do some extra work to convert
whatever data you had from the free version
into the paid version.
So in-app billing really enables that pay
model very well.
So today we wanted to talk about well, how
do you go about implementing in-app billing.
And then we'd love to hear some questions.
So just an overview.
With in-app billing there's really two types
of items that you can have.
One are managed items.
And these are typically things that you only
buy once.
And we'll talk about the details of these.
Then we have unmanaged items as well.
Now, when it comes to the implementation side
of it t, here's actually, you can do an in-app
billing implementation that's entirely client-side.
Or you can have a version of it where you've
got some of that data stored on your server.
And we're going to look at how that process
varies between the two and what advantages
and disadvantages you can have.
So, managed items.
These are typically, as I mentioned, items
that you only buy once.
So, if you have a book or an app that's like
a book, you might have some episodic content,
where you provide chapter one of that app
or that content for free.
And then users can pay to unlock chapter two
and then chapter three and so on.
And in the case of a game it might not be
chapters, it could be levels.
It could be characters.
And so on and so forth.
Now, one of the features that we have in in-app
billing is that your client, your app, can
actually ask to replay transactions.
Now this sort of thing is useful for users
that kind of install the app on multiple devices
and you wanna make sure those purchases transfer
across.
But you know there can be times where if you
found some gray areas in your logic where
for some reason that transaction even though
it was successful, your app hasn't picked
it up.
You've got this option to replay transactions
and restore the users [unintelligible].
So managed items are really great.
They're called managed items because we allow
you to be able to replay them and we track
them for you so and so.
The next type of items are unmanaged items.
And these are not typically the type of items
that you only consume or purchase once.
So in the case of a game, it might be some
in-game coins.
So you wanna allow the user to purchase these
coin packs more than once.
Or it could be potions, whatever.
In the case of an app or a service that you're
providing, you could also do something like
ask the user to pay X amount of money every
month or every year.
Today I wouldn't actually use in-app billing
for that recurring payment because we actually
have subscription billing.
Which is very similar to in-app billing.
But it automatically sort of recurs for your
refreshes.
So subscription billing is a separate topic.
But I guess the end of this slide is talking
about unmanaged items.
Now because they're unmanaged items, it means
that we as in Google Play don't manage them
for you.
You can't ask to have them replayed.
So you need to keep track of that state information
yourself.
And this is where some of that service side
implementation may actually help you.
Alright.
So let's go to the next slide.
This here is a flow chart.
And what we wanna show you is this kinda flow
that you get from your application.
And how those requests and responses work.
So the top half of the screen is the Google
Play server.
And then everything below that dotted line
is really the device itself.
Now for in-app billing, there's two critical
components.
One is your app.
The other part is the Google Play client.
And we're gonna see how the Google Play client
is really involved here.
So what happens in terms of how we secure
this data.
We actually have, your app will have a public
key that you generate.
The play server has a private key.
Now from your app what you do is you use your
billing service to make a billing request.
And your app is actually, when you make that
billing request, it's making it locally on
the device to start with.
It goes to the Google Play client.
The Google Play client then, actually forwards
on that billing request to the Google Play
server.
Where it's processed and the users have an
opportunity to you know, say "Hey, I wanna
pay for it using this credit card."
Or if they've bought a Nexus7 they might have
some credit left over so they might choose
that purchasing option.
But anyway, so it's purchased at the Google
Play server side.
And then we get a response that's signed by
the Google Play server with that private key
we talked about.
That response is passed back to the Google
Play client which in turn passes the response
back to your app.
To your billing receiver component.
You then use that public key to decrypt that
message and process it how you want.
So that's basically telling you "Hey, the
purchase succeeded."
Or occasionally maybe tell you things like
"The purchase failed."
And there are a number of failure states that
you do need to take care of.
For example the user's credit card may not
have had the funds.
Or the purchase may have been declined for
whatever reason.
And you have extensive documentation on these
scenarios that you need to support on developer.Android.com.
Well this is the client version.
And you can see it's fairly straight forward
when you look at it step by step.
Let's now talk about a version of this where
we introduce your own server.
So you see now we have two dotted lines.
So above the topmost dotted line we have the
Google Play server.
And in the middle there, in between the two
dotted lines is the device.
And we have the Google Play client in your
app.
And then below the dotted line we have your
server.
Now you'll notice that the public key is no
longer sitting in your app itself.
It's now sitting on your server.
That's how, where we're going to use it.
But let's now look at the flow of how this
part of it works.
The app will make the billing request which
gets forwarded onto the Google Play server.
The Google Play server will respond and sign
it with the private key.
And then that signed response will actually
be passed back to your app to its billing
receiver.
So so far it is actually the same at that
client-side version.
But this is where it differs.
Your app will then take that, whatever credentials
it has, and pass it through your sever.
Including that sort of signed response.
So let's do a deep dive into what that part
of it is.
The, your app, your server side.
[clears throat]
So what happens is, your server takes those
credentials and returns back a session token
to your client.
It's obviously utilized that public key.
Or it will do so.
Then we take that session token into your
app.
Your app then requests content with that session
token.
Now, you should follow the best practices
around the session token.
Make sure they expire after so long.
And you know, the point of this token is,
it's really the [unintelligible] between your
app and your server.
It should really be used to set up a session.
Every time the client contacts the server.
So, once you pass that content with that session
token, you can then, your server can then
return the content.
Now this is that scenario with the unmanaged
items.
You can do it this way if you wanna track
information server-side.
Now of course, this is going to work for a
device.
Because presumably when you add those credentials
you're gaining some information from your
app.
Now, on the server you may choose to have
your own user accounts on, where you're tracking
them.
So that when the users fire up your app they're
basically saying "Hey, I'm signing in as Bob
and my password is, password123."
And then your server's able to track which
for that particular identity, what items,
unmanaged items have been purchased.
And then that way you can restore [unintelligible].
So that's the, that's the server version of
in-app billing.
So when you're developing this, you probably
wanna do a lot of sample testing or prototyping.
So what we've implemented are some test-IDs.
That are reserved.
That you can use to simulate different scenarios.
So, this is a good way to actually verify
the code if you're using automatic unit test.
You can use these prompt IDs when you make
the requests so that you get the responses
back straight away.
And you know, we're simulating the response
request response here.
It's not actually going to go through all
of those steps that we talked about.
But during development we'd use this.
But there comes a time when you wanna actually
test with real purchases.
So, there are a few more steps that you need
to do when you're testing real purchases.
First you need to go into your publisher site
and register some test accounts.
Now these test accounts are typically any
other Google account.
So let's say I'm the developer.
And I'm sitting here and I'm saying "Hey,
look we need to add our testers."
And Tony and Anirudh are my testers, I would
go and grab their email address, register
it on the publisher's site.
So that when users, when Anirudh and Tony
make these requests, it knows that these are
test accounts.
Now I'll tell you why it becomes important.
What we then need to do is that go and upload
our APK to the Play Store.
But leave it in an unpublished state.
Because right now we're testing it, right?
We don't wanna publish it and make it available
to the world.
Then what we do is go and add our products.
The in-app purchases that we have.
We're gonna go and add those to the publisher
site.
And here's a very important part.
You need to go and publish those items there
and then.
Don't leave those items in an unpublished
or draft state.
Because otherwise your app won't be able to
find it.
It'll say "Hey, I didn't recognize this particular
item ID."
And it's perfectly safe to publish these items.
Because your app has still not been published.
So nobody else will be able to make those
purchases.
In fact, and this is where those test accounts
are important, only those test accounts and
the publisher account will be able to make
those purchases.
Because the app is still unpublished.
So, publish your items, but leave your app
unpublished.
So once we've added our SKUs or our app product
list what we would do is install our app on
a real device.
You can't use the emulator because the emulator
doesn't have the Google Play store on it.
And remember as we said earlier you need the
Google Play client to actually go and make
these purchases.
Now for those test accounts that we talked
about, they have to be the primary account
on each of those devices that you're testing
on.
So, by primary account, ideally what you want,
primary account, the notion of the primary
account has become a little bit foggier.
But typically it's the first account that
you added to the device.
Now if you've got some testing devices that
you've added, there are some other accounts
on there, what you would need to do is do
a factory reset.
And then go and add those test accounts that
you registered on step one.
Then, those test accounts can go and read
the APK and make purchases.
Now these are going to be real purchases.
Right?
We're going to go through the whole process
of actually billing those credit cards when
you make these purchases.
So from the publisher side, you need to go
and manually refund those purchases when you're
finished testing.
That part is really important.
If you don't go ahead and refund your test
purchases, you could rack up pretty large
bills.
So it is your responsibility to go and manually
refund those via the publisher side.
So that's it.
During the testing phase you're actually exercising
the full end to end purchase mechanism.
And we're actually getting responses.
And we're making requests to the Google Play
client and getting them back from the Google
Play server as well.
So we're really simulating real world situations
here.
[unintelligible]
>>Tony: So, I had a small thing to add on
testing.
That's, so, recently we had some issue with
testing account set up for billing testing.
And it was a issue on our end.
And it gave some developer impressions actually
that they can not test billing with test account.
So, but it's actually it was a issue earlier.
And that should be fixed now.
So, so testing with test accounts should be
working now.
>>Ankur: OK.
Great.
That's a good point.
Yeah, it's just something over the last couple
of weeks that we believe it's been resolved.
But if you had some issues it should be fixed
now.
If it isn't, please do let us know.
>>Tony: Let us know.
Yeah.
>>Ankur: OK.
So that's a really high level overview of
in-app billing.
We today wanted to just introduce the concept.
We know many developers that are using them.
And in-app billing has been very successful
on Google Play.
We think that more developers should adopt
the user in-app purchases or in-app billing.
Because it does at the end of the day provide
a really nice user experience.
So with that, let's take some questions.
We don't actually have anyone live on the
Hangout today.
So if there's people that can post on the
thread, in the Hangout on the thread that's
on the Google+ stream, that would be great.
If not, let's move to Google Moderator and
I'll hand it over to Anirudh.
>>Anirudh: I would just like to add something
to the presentation.
Some developers have asked me about support
in different countries for in-app billing.
And because we use the same [wire] infrastructure
behind scenes, it's pretty much the same support
as the status support for paid apps.
So that's one of the considerations for in-app
billing.
[pause]
>>Ankur: OK.
Do we wanna bring up the Moderator thread?
>>Anirudh: Yes.
So in the first question there is, and this
is from Ian, Orange, California.
The first question is, "I'd like to use in-app
billing for donations.
Is this an appropriate use or would you recommend
using an external system?"
Tony would you like to take that?
[pause]
Tony we cannot hear you.
>>Tony: Sorry.
So for in-app billing for donations.
So we don't have any like, special policy
to prevent developer using in-app billing
for donation.
But one thing you need to keep in mind is,
so for donation using Google Wallet, it just
like, regular how you use Google Checkout
Wallet in the past like for doing, for donation.
You have to be a verified, valid non-profit
organization.
In other words, it's a 501C3 or 501C6 organization.
So we have a process to verify these organization.
And as long as you satisfy this criteria then
you can use in-app billing for donation.
>>Anirudh: OK.
Thanks Tony.
The second question is most, is from Romania.
And the questions is "Most of my clients are
requesting a calendar component into their
applications.
So far I was using a custom calendar component
from a GitHub user.
I was wondering if you."
Sorry.
"I was wondering if you're thinking to release
a standard widget which would support this
functionality?"
We o not have a UI widget for a calendar built
in that you could embed.
But starting I think, ICS, we do have a calendar
provider.
Which you can query to get the calendar data.
And kind of use the widget to put that on
your application.
Yeah.
So, anything more you guys would like to add?
>>Ankur: No.
I guess the calendar widget that we provide
for users today is part of the AOSP.
So Android open source project.
So you can certainly go and have them look
a the code for that widget today.
And see if you wanna build something similar
to that itself.
>>Anirudh: Thanks Ankur.
Also, if you're using a pre-ICS device, or
writing for pre-ICS devices, there's a calendar
API that's part of the Google API client library
and you could also get calendar, user calendar
data from there.
Once you authorize using OAuth.
So let's move to the next question.
Which is again from Romania.
"Hello.
Trying to remove a dialog when coming from
back task to front task gives me a illegal
state exception.
Cannot perform this action after on save instant
state.
Can you help me on this matter?"
So this seems like a life cycle issue.
I do not have any specific answer but I do
not understand what you're trying to do.
So maybe if you have some good-- "Trying to
remove a dialog."
Is this a fragment dialog or a regular progress
dialog?
Mm.
Guys do you have any inputs?
>>Ankur: From memory, this sort of issue occurs,
it is definitely a life-cycle issue.
And it's because some certain code is being
invoked out of sequence basically.
Or relying on, I'm trying to remember what
the details are.
Because there are several ways to end up in
this.
But I think you're trying to rely on this
state of certain, it could be a fragment--.
>>Tony: So I, from what I remember, like,
this exception tends to happen in two places.
One is if someone trying to do things in the
AsyncTask and, or trying to update, do a fragment
transaction, , when using AsyncTask or using
loaders.
Because some of this operation can be, can
still happen actually, even the activity go
off the screen.
So, and past the safe instant state.
And the framework is very conservative trying
to prevent these kind of states happen.
Even in reality in most of the time, your
activity is still in, not in that state.
So, I guess the solution or, I think you really
need to look into whether it's proper to update
the UI actually in those scenario.
And because things could happen.
Actually after the activity got recycled off
of or past the safe instance state.
So you have to see whether it makes sense
actually trying to do some of these UI updates.
And one way to avoid the exception but not
necessarily the best solution is to have a
fragment keep track of what state you are
in.
And if you're, if your state is not actually
in that state, you just, you can do the fragment
transaction or things otherwise.
Just skip it.
Because you don't, you're not actually, your
own activity is not actually on the UI anymore.
So.
>>Anirudh: So thanks Tony.
So yeah, just look for a life cycle method
before safe instance.
Probably on plus or somewhere.
And you can place your request for removing
the dialog there.
Depending on whether it's a progress or a
fragment dialog you may need to do a fragment
transaction.
So I think that's it.
That's all the questions we had in Moderator.
So.
Yeah that kind of brings us to the end of
this Hangout.
Guys do you have anything more to add?
>>Ankur: Yeah.
Just one last thing.
Next week's Hangout will, just for next week,
we're changing the day of the week that we're
doing it.
So only next week we're going to do it on
Tuesday.
Tony and I will, as we mentioned, we're going
to be in Hong Kong on Monday.
We're also going to be in Hong Kong on Tuesday.
So we'll be running the Hangout together in
the same location for once.
From Hong Kong on Tuesday.
So stay tuned.
We'll make the, post the new time and a Moderator
link for you as soon as we can.
So with that--
>>Tony: And again, if you happen to be in
Hong Kong at that, on the 24th, please join
us to the GDG event at night.
On the 24th.
So, Ankur and I and Felix, we will be there.
And we're happy to meet with you guys and
talk about Android or anything about Google.
>>Ankur: OK, well thanks everyone for joining
and we will catch you next time.
>>Tony: Thanks.
>>Anirudh: Thanks.
Bye-bye.